and my next guests are comedians uh best
friends and moms who are all about
breaking down the good
bad and ugly of motherhood and their
podcast i'm on so hard i love them
so much after i got to do this one thing
with them please welcome kristen hensley
and jen smedley young
welcome to the show thank you for having
us if you can tell we're
really freaking out and excited we're
trying to play it cool i was so happy
you could physically be here because
sometimes guess it's weird when people
can physically and not you know and not
be here so i was so glad i got to see in
person this time are you kidding we're
physically here and i'm physically like
strapped in with spaghetti
we're all in it together yes well meet
jessica
hi hey so tell everybody about your
podcast i'm on so hard
well um it's called my mom so hard but
really it's about friendship because
we've been friends for a long time and
then we had kids and realized
early on like the only way to survive
motherhood is
your friends sisterhood sisterhood
making you laugh
like pulling you out of a funk and we
thought let's just be unapologetic and
talk about what we
are thinking about up at 3am while we're
breastfeeding and see if other
moms see like the terrible job that
we're doing
maybe they'll feel better about the
mediocre job that they're doing
so or just relate because people are
probably
thinking the same like similar things
and in similar spaces and it's okay to
like sometimes be like
ah yeah like you don't have it all
figured out and sometimes it's scary and
lonely and
it's not this big like jump in the ocean
with your hair
blowing like sometimes it's dirty and
gritty and hard yeah that was like when
people were pregnant they were like you
glow and i'm like you know what i can't
with you right now because some of us
didn't
um so as a mom though we all know things
can get messy
frustrating and just plain infuriating
um
and and try doing it in the middle of a
pandemic uh when you're trying to get
one kid to sit still
um for remote learning while the other
is playing a little game called i wonder
what mommy's makeup tastes like so
sometimes the only way
to get through it is to phone a mommy
friend and and i don't know do you agree
jessica your mommy friends
oh yeah i mean i didn't even know
how important that was like the village
to help me raise my children is
definitely online
you know it's finding you know podcasts
like
yours or um you know certainly any kind
of
group where there's real you can relate
to
just these moments where you're like
you're in target
and your breasts are just like leaking
all over the place
and your giant pad has
slid to the side and you're trying to
shop for
that gene that stretchy gene that you
may be able to squeeze yourself
into because you haven't seen jeans in
about six months
um yeah i could totally relate to that
as you're sweating all over the place
and your child
has sorry
that's so true and they're playing with
their poop
and you're like that's cool and we don't
approve of this at home
anyone watching i'm a good mom i promise
well wait it's time to call our mommy
friends and share our war stories
but not without wine people so let's
grab some wine
we have some flying in now somebody can
pour i can pour it all but wait you have
to because of covid
we have to individually like get the
glasses
she's so close i know do you smell oh
declaration
i'm not even great at pouring wine i'm
not that's like so sloppy i usually
turn the glass but i'm not allowed to
touch the glass you do gen pores this is
that's right
yes okay so you have to grab your own so
that your glass is literally heavy
yeah yes you should get a workout in
while you're in a city
exactly well i didn't fill it to the rim
so it's still
it's still classy i'm so good grab your
glasses ladies do you have some oh you
have some as well
all right it's less one to mommy y'all
this is what this is called
i know some people are chugging it it's
not a contest but if it is
but if it is i'm getting the rhythm well
cheers to everyone
um we're taking any and all motherhood
questions from our house seats um as
well as from twitter
the first question is from patrice in
our house seats
so patrice what's up hi ladies hi
one seven and one one year old and i'll
be honest
especially during the quarantine to
avoid the says
and the tantrums they're like can i
snack all day
yes can i have ice cream for lunch yes
can i be on the ipad all day okay
here's the charger so my
ladies is what mommy said are you
sorry not sorry for committing i have
been
deep diving into halloween decorations
and i say that it's because
my kids love them but really it's
because i love them we're the same human
i literally
literally upstairs in my office just
finished one of my etsy orders
we're doing nightmare before christmas
like a whole theme for halloween that's
the whole i have like a whole portion of
the garage that's just boxes of
halloween
and i say it's for them but it's not
it's for me it makes me happy
so happy to be happy why do we call it a
mommy sin
we should call like mommy innovation and
we're not thinking
forward or mommy doing it for yourself
because we deserve it because no one
plans a pandemic
you're doing great girl i don't think
you're doing anything wrong
yeah i do let my kids have my kids
generally it was usually just an
an ice cream on the weekends kind of
thing like it was because i was like
look ghost of christmas future ladies
like i was like
you just slow the roll with the sugar
while you can and so i usually save it
for a treat
um but i have i have you know it'll be a
wednesday sometimes and i'll be like
okay okay everybody was good today you
know nobody completely lost their mind
and made me want to cry and
go somewhere else so let's do ice cream
jessica how about you well um
peppa pig has been raising my
two-year-old
so there's that and
um definitely get the popsicle a day
a hundred percent yes i hear that peppa
pig i thought that my child was going to
have a british accent
you watched it so much you know what
our show that i've that's the thing that
i'm doing wrong and i know it is our
kids only watch one
show so we've had they've literally seen
bunt
like every single season your kids are
older mine's sick she loves bunk i'm
like
i was like you're six this is like too
old but anyway the next question is from
jessica in the house seats
jessica what's your question hi ladies
i'm jess
i'm a mom to two beautiful little girls
ages six and four
and i like to teach my daughters the
correct words for things including body
parts
so when my oldest was free we were
sitting in my mom's church
and out of nowhere she starts yelling
out my vagina hurt
[Laughter]
so my question is what is the most
awkward moment
created by your child and how did you
handle it
oh man i'll have one look at your face i
want to know the story
so i have a seven and a five year old
and we
do the same thing we're like they have
to learn what they're called like the
medical terms so they can describe on
their body what they're called
and i decided they have to stop bathing
together because last week when my son
stood up
my daughter goes uh daschle your penis
looks like
a funny little hot dog that's so gross
so more inaccurate right so more
embarrassing for him than anybody else
but i was like
but that's the thing you've got to say
the right term so like good on you
like she's using the right words because
if you name it something else they're
gonna wash their elbow
and like you're in a bigger problem area
at that point
my mom was visiting and she's old school
and my daughter came in and she was like
mommy my
my vagina hurts my underpants are too
tight and i was like i get that that's
no that's not fun for anybody and then
my mom was like
kristen tell her to call it a lily
oh really what why are we like
why are we calling it a lillian it's not
a plush toy
it looks like a lily mine's like a
driven over lily because i've had two
kids so
that is good i don't call it anything i
call it by the body parts but mine isn't
mine isn't body parts so much as mine my
son he's for
y'all and he is highly entertained with
himself and he and what am i
i don't want to shame him like but i'm
like okay well this is private time you
know because i'm always like
remy quit grabbing it and he's like and
then he'll literally be like it's
getting bigger
and i'm like oh my gosh
and i'm i you know i'm a woman telling a
little boy so i'm just i'm like
you know hey everything's cool but like
this is your private time like we don't
maybe
say that in target maybe talk about it
and maybe try not to touch yourself so
much
just throwing it out there i don't know
i'm still getting my husband to stop
i mean from your rv stories i know you
have to have some kind of embarrassing
kid story
yes um when my oldest honor was in
preschool she went to one of those
preschools where like
the preschool teachers like to write
down cute little quotes from
every kid and there was like a a message
board that all of the
the parents and everyone can sign in and
see what the kid
says that day and honor was four years
old
and the teacher thought it was so
hilarious that she had to email me
directly and let me know
that um honor's quote for the day was
i just can't wait till i get older so i
can drink wine she said drink vino and
drive
like i do that at the same time like i'm
drinking vino and driving
and she was like can't wait to be like
mommy
because she probably can't wait to drive
you